hey guys my name is Jess McDonald it's
the 11th of July today and you were
tuned into my top 5 show where I
bringing my five favorite things that
happened in the whole gaming week so
let's get going if you're keen for
destiny the game not the concept then
you probably be interested in all the
details that dropped about the title
this week you can find a nitty gritty on
gamespot but we've heard that the beta
which launches July 17 on PlayStation
well be made available to xbox systems
on july 23 Activision and bungie also
announced the $35 destiny expansion pass
which gives you access to two expansions
packed with new story missions co-op
activities and multiplayer arenas as
well as new weapons and gear you'll save
five bucks off the DL see if you get the
passer take that I'll leave it there are
also three collector's editions ranging
from 90 bucks to 150 with different bits
and pieces from DLC content to a fancy
replica of ghost that lights up and dogs
if all this DLC talk has you missed then
you're probably going to want to have a
word with new be soft you've said that
gamers are now pretty accepting at the
fascia VP of digital publishing Chris
early has told games industry
international that when it comes to DLC
such as Ben assassins creed 4 black flag
there was no resistance maybe there were
12 guys somewhere who said something but
whatever as a whole there wasn't a
problem early is referring to time saver
DLC packs which unlock resources and
hidden locations to speed up your play
he went on to speak generally about the
somewhat controversial feature
explaining DLC is pretty much accepted
season pass is pretty much accepted now
it's interesting when you start to think
of season pass as a service pass for our
season pass holders I know we hold
events for them specifically so it's a
little bit more than just DLC content so
there's an evolution going on there
apparently a bunch of ps4 owners have
never played the last of us well I hear
you say that's because the last of it
isn't out on ps4 yet babs a little more
accurately apparently a bunch of ps4
users never owned a ps3 a lot of you
have been asking why anyone would buy an
HD remaster of a game they've played but
according to Sony it makes sense for a
lot of gamers who never got around to it
Sony exact Josh Walker told MCV it would
be almost unfair for all our new fence
to never play a game like this
while we're on the topic of remastering
gains it seems that uncharted maybe the
next on the chopping block the chopping
block being the platform for improving
and remastering games ok that hold
shopping block metaphor with support
choice playstation worldwide studios
boss Shuhei Yoshida has said that people
may have missed the Uncharted series
which makes it a good candidate for an
HD remaster at the same time he told
Eurogamer he doesn't want to flood the
market with remakes but it's something
they will continue to consider where
it's appropriate
and now my favorite thing that happened
this week 16 whole minutes of sweet
sweet dragon age inquisition footage the
video is an alpha build but we get to
see the freaking enormous and lovely
looking game world NPCs combat and some
epic dragon fighting because you know
dragon age the video is narrated by
creative director Mike Laidlaw and among
other things shows off the tactical
approach you can take to combat and
focus abilities which let the player
slow down time in order to hit your
opponent's harder and with more accuracy
be sure to check out the meaty video on
gamespot for way more gameplay tidbit
and now for your question of the day let
me know your opinion on what Ubisoft
says about DLC are you generally a fan
or can you do without this week on site
check out our features on what you can
expect from no man's sky find out my
picks for games you should get around to
completing on the gist and skyrim mods
highlight superhero check in Tamriel
that is it for me this week thanks for
tuning in and leaving me your opinions
and I will see you again on Monday